was halten sie jetzt angela merkels rede
hat sie den richtigen ton getroffen den
richtigen ton hat sie auf jeden fall
getroffen sie hat tatsächlich das getan
was ich viele menschen erhofft erwünscht
ersehnt haben von ihr anders an das herz
der der millionen menschen in diesem
land zu appellieren und zu sprechen und
zu zeigen dass sie nicht nur eine
naturwissenschaftlerin ist sondern
genauso besorgt ist über diese krise wie
millionen menschen auch allerdings muss
ich auch gleichzeitig sagen ich kann gar
nicht so viel meditieren wie unsere frau
denkt man eben vorgeschlagen hat um mich
nicht zu ereifern über diese über diese
rede weil nachdem wir jetzt mehrere
wochen darauf gewartet hat dass es mal
eine rede tatsächlich gibt an die
menschen
hätte ich mir jetzt mehr erhofft als
waschen sie sich die hände
erhalten sie sich an die regeln und
sonst kommen noch härtere maßnahmen ich
hätte mir erhofft dass die kanzlerin den
millionen menschen in diesem land die
sich fragen wenn der märz zu ende geht
und ich dann kein geld mehr habe und ich
habe mir bei eine wohnung gekauft und
ich möchte die rate weiter bezahlen und
ich habe angst vom gerichtsvollzieher
was unsere regierung dafür tut
vielleicht sind wir da an dem punkt gar
nicht so weit auseinander paul hat
erwähnt was ist da in österreich an
konkreten den gut was hat sie uns
konkret gesagt nichts nichts nichts kein
einziges wort es gab kein einziges wort
darüber was diese regierung jetzt für
die menschen tut was die regierung mit
steuer über schüssen mit milliarden
steuer überschüssen geld was die
menschen in diesem land erwirtschaftet
haben tut um den menschen zu helfen
wir wissen es gibt beute gemacht und die
meisten menschen keine ahnung wie sie
diese maßnahmen abrufen sollten aber
ganz ganz ganz konkret der mensch der
sagt ich habe all das getan was dieses
land diese gesellschaft von mir erwartet
ich habe mich solidarisch verhalten
ich bin zur arbeit gegangen ich habe
steuern gezeigt ich habe für mein alter
vorgesorgt indem ich eine wohnung
gekauft habe
die rate ist ende april fällig meine
firma ist pleite einer eisdiele macht zu
wir gehen auf kurzarbeit wird wie zahle
ich das kann ich mich darauf verlassen
dass ich meine wohnung behalte meine
altersvorsorge kann ich mich darauf
verlassen
das hätte ich mir von angela merkel
erhofft außer zu sagen dass ich mich
jetzt von älteren leuten verhalten hat
weil das weiß ich seit drei wochen das
höre ich seit drei wochen daran hält
sich das land seit 3
das ist vielleicht das land daran hält
doch ist ja gerade die natürlich auch
die plätze in deutschland an
es gibt so viele bilder wo man eben
sieht dass sich die menschen nicht daran
halten es gibt beispiele in europa in
ganz ganz vielen ländern wo das nicht
geschieht und das war der wahre grund
warum die kanzlerin heute sozusagen zur
nation gesprochen hat und man kann finde
ich auf gar keinen fall erwarten dass
sie in einer solchen kurzen rede ganz
konkrete antworten auf all diese fragen
nein auf all diese fragen wird es
antworten geben es gibt bereits ein
schutzschirm ist gibt den finanzminister
der zusammen mit dem arbeitsminister an
diesem gearbeitet hat und ich finde
nachdem wir von der kanzlerin gefordert
haben nicht nur wir sondern alle in
diesem land eine emotionale ansprache zu
halten darüber was corona bedeutet nein
moment was corona bedeutet und wo es
darum geht erst mal dafür zu sorgen dass
sich dieses virus nicht weiter
ausbreitet und das tut man auch durch
kommunikation dass die menschen sich
nicht versammeln und vor allem dass es
nicht dazu kommt dass es in deutschland
auch eine ausgangssperre gibt denn das
hätte dann wirklich noch viel
dramatische auswirkungen auf die
wirtschaftlich finde man kann vor der
kanzlerin nicht verlangen in so einer
kurzen ansprache wo es um emotionen geht
zu verlangen dass sie hier eine
wirtschafts liste aufstellt und für
jeden einzelnen eine frage beantwortet
also erstmal würde ich dazu sage ich
gebe den ganz vielen punkten recht aber
emotionen zahlen nun mal keine miete von
emotionen und davon dass ich das gefühl
habe die kanzlerin ist genauso besorgt
wie ich bezahle ich nicht die miete
beteiligt nicht dass es aber die
menschen zahlen wenn sie hatte bedeutete
dann das geld wird ja aber das mich
jetzt einmal ausgeben die kanzlerin hat
meiner meinung nach keinen
erziehungsauftrag sie es voll ist es
vollkommen richtig dass sie mahnt und
das anmahnt und einfordert was die
besten wissenschaftler die wir zur
verfügung haben wir raten vollkommen
richtig dass sie das in emotionalen
worten tod vollkommen richtig aber zu
sagen liebe mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger
ich weiß ende des monats oder anfang
april wird die miete fällig und deswegen
verspreche ich euch bis ende april bis
ende märz sagen wir euch wie wir dafür
sorgen können dass ihr eure schulden
euren kredite wenn ihr keinen job mehr
habt wenn ihr in kurzarbeit wie er das
bedienen können ich verspreche das ist
ein satz der hätte in 20 minuten
reingepasst aber wie soll sie etwas
versprechen wenn eine lage so überhaupt
sehen wir rechnen bei deutschen erhalten
sie hat den deutschen damals versprochen
dass ihre sparbücher sicher sind jeder
wusste dass dieses versprechen nur so
lange hält wie es getestet wird bis es
getestet wird dann wäre es
zusammengebrochen wenn die leute alle
zur bank gegangen
trotzdem war es richtig das zu sagen
weil es den menschen suggeriert hat ihr
seid wirtschaftlich sicher es geht nicht
nur um es geht nicht nur um gesundheit
es geht für sehr viele menschen auch um
wirtschaftliche gesundheit und ums
wirtschaftliche überleben und dazu hat
sie kein wort aber sonst kriegst das
beispiel an dass die menschen in 2009
nicht zu den banken gerannt sind jetzt
rennen sie aber zu den supermärkten und
das ist momentan tut mir leid dass noch
viel größere probleme das ist
mittlerweile darum geht ob die
versorgung
ob es eine versorgungs knappheit in
deutschland gehen da gibt es um
psychologie und da geht es vor allem
moment da geht es vor allem um die frage
wie man mit diesem virus umgeht und ob
man es schafft die deutsche bevölkerung
davon zu überzeugen diesen maßnahmen
jetzt zu entsprechen und das ist das
entscheidende was die ganzen und damit
wollte es gab ja auch in dem fall in der
vergangenheit du tust jetzt so erzählte
sie noch nie darüber gesprochen was das
ganze für wirtschaftliche auswirkungen
hat das stimmt ja überhaupt nicht es gab
in den vergangenen tagen immer wieder
pressekonferenzen wo sie sich
präsentiert hat zusammen teilweise mit
dem finanzminister mit dem
wirtschaftsminister wo über diese
konsequenzen gesprochen wurde und ich
finde man kann jetzt nicht den vorwurf
machen dass sie da auf jede einzelne
dieser fragen keine antworten geben halt
doch nicht auf jede einzelne dieser
fragen ich sage auch ganz zentraler
fragen antworten von denen wir wissen
dass sie beruhigend wirken und vor allem
antworten von denen wir wissen dass
menschen sie erwarten und dass menschen
sie zurecht aber hat michael du hast
gesagt die menschen laufen in die
supermärkte glaubst du ernsthaft dass
nach der rede leute jetzt nicht in die
supermärkte gehen und sagen
die kanzlerin hat gesagt die supermärkte
beim volk auf morgen nicht mehr acht
pakete klopapier sondern nur noch eins
weil die kanzlerin gesagt hat das ist
unsolidarisch nein diese rede befördert
am ende vielleicht sogar unsicherheit
weil sie eben nicht sagt worauf menschen
sich verlassen können sie sagt sie
können sich darauf verlassen dass die
supermärkte folgt auf der a4 hier
außerhalb von berlin sehen wir 60
kilometer stau
wo ist denn zum beispiel die logistik
der bundeswehr
wo ist denn die konkrete maßnahme die
und sagt wie bleiben denn die
supermärkte voll
warum soll ich das glauben dass die
supermärkte voll bleiben ist
seine aussage aber das reicht doch nicht
allein um menschen das gefühl zu geben
ihr werdet ihr werdet wirtschaftlich
halbwegs leben durch diese krise aber du
tust ja so als sei die kanzlerin jetzt
die einzige die noch regierungshandeln
bevor es gibt andere minister wie julia
klöckner die sich insbesondere dafür
eingesetzt hat diese bundeswehr zur
diskussion zu stellen da bin ich ganz
mit einer deiner meinung
das ist natürlich die
verteidigungsministerin längst hätte
klar machen müssen dass die armee
sozusagen auch dafür eingesetzt wird die
leute in den logistischen notsituationen
zu unterstützen aber dass jetzt alles an
einer rede an die nation gerichtet war
in einer in einer lage wo es um diesen
virus insbesondere geht das finde ich
viel zu einfach wenn wir zeit ich weiss
nicht wie vielen jahren seit gefühlt
einem jahrzehnt über die schwarze null
reden und steuerbeschlüsse haben kriege
ich jetzt was von diesem geld was ich
erwirtschaftet habe zurück und das ist
ein punkt der mich auch an der rede
tatsächlich massiv gestört hat die hatte
man kann sagen einen emotionalen ton und
einen besorgten sie hatte aber auch ein
bisschen den ton nach dem motto 'jetzt
benehmt euch mal ja und da muss ich
einfach sagen die leute benehmen sich
seit zwei wochen die leute benehmen sich
nehmen
man kann leute die seit zwei wochen
alles mitmachen was die regierung sagt
nicht in einem ton gegenüber treten der
so tut als würden sie das nicht tun und
das hat sie getan hat richtigerweise
vorhin gesagt es gibt noch immer viele
parks cafés wo viele menschen noch immer
draußen sind man muss ja auch dagegen
trotzdem noch etwas mehr aktuell macht
sich so viel viel zu einfach
und fragt nach antworten die ist leider
so in der form nicht gibt auch angela
merkel steht in der größten krise in
ihrer geschichte die ganze welt und ist
es ja nicht so dass wenn wir uns um uns
herum gucken und all die anderen länder
das ist der antworten gibt nein das ist
quatsch auch wenn du über österreich
spricht auch da wenn man mit den
politikern dort sprich die da haben die
menschen keine antwort ich kenne viele
die in österreich leben die jetzt in
einer verlassenen basel wo es eine
ausgangssperre gibt und wo sie vor dem
wirtschaftlichen kollaps stehen so und
wenn wir über kredite sprechen über
kredite ja die angeboten werden
das gab ist bei angela merkel und dem
ist um solche momente
jetzt muss ich jetzt muss ich auch mal
aussprechen es sollte dir zu denken
geben dass es eine koalition aus cem
özdemir und wolfgang bosbach einem
erklärten merkel kritiker gibt der die
das komplett anders sehen weil du diese
rede
völlig falsch betrachtet ist es geht
hier nicht darum dass angela merkel wie
in anderen pressekonferenzen
spiegelstrich abarbeitet sondern und du
sprichst über erziehung es geht darum
natürlich darauf hinzuweisen dass diese
maßnahmen wirken müssen weil es sonst
eine ausgangssperre geben könnte
die noch viel dramatischer ist und das
war das ziel der rede
und dieses ziel erreicht also erstens
wenn es eine solche koalition gibt und
wenn alle in einem parlament
parteiübergreifend einer meinung sind
sind dann sollten uns das wirklich zu
denken geben und zwar sollte es uns
kritisch nachfragen lassen und nicht
einschränkend sagen wenn alle einer
meinung sind dann jetzt geht der
kanzlerin maniche kritiker zeigen doch
dass das geht doch darum wenn er das
denn darüber rede richtig betrachtet ist
uns um dieses ziel der rede gehört sogar
vielleicht ein freund du hast das wort
gerade richtig gesagt was gesagt es sind
kredite angeboten worden
erstens in kredite für firmen angeboten
worden also wenn ich hier sehe ich auch
zu hause und nein es geht um einzelne
personen die angst um einen totalverlust
ihres vermögens um ihre altersvorsorge
haben und wenn ich hier bin
der chef der deutschen bank oder wenn
ich einen mittelständischen
weltmarktführer habe dann weiß ich
ungefähr ich melde mich bei meiner
zuständigen landes waren dem prozess
krieg ich hin aber wenn ich ein ganz
normaler mensch bin der ganz normal zur
arbeit geht und ganz normal seine rate
für seine wohnung abbezahlt dann weiß
ich das erst mal nicht und den prozess
den gibt es bisher einfach nicht und
lasse mich da musste man muss auch
innerhalb der regierung auch ein
bisschen dass angela merkel aber man hat
er seinen einzelnen deutschen bereit
sagen kann dass es dann kredit und so
bezeichnete das ist ja auch völlig
normalen aber man hätte sagen können man
hätte zum beispiel sagen können ende des
monats wenn die miete fällig wird oder
anfang des monats kommt drauf an wie es
im vertrag steht werden wir liebe
mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger eine
antwort für euch haben klare helle des
monats wir haben gar nicht was morgen
und übermorgen ist was soll die
kanzlerin
eine antwort auf ende des monats haben
es tut mir leid das erwarte ich dann von
der bundeskanzlerin dass sie zu mir sagt
wir arbeiten daran
bis ende des monats eine antwort auf die
fragen und auch ein ganz wichtiges wort
du hast kredite gesagt ich meine keine
kredite
ich meine dass die usa 500 milliarden
dollar 500 milliarden dollar soforthilfe
das sind keine kredite
das sind keine kredite das cash auf die
hand für ihre bürger für ihre
steuerzahler bereitstellt für ihre
steuerzahler nicht für firmen für ihre
steuerzahler das versprechen kann heute
donald trump ist genauso lange in der
korona krise wie angela merkel gestern
hatte den airline 15 airlines 50
milliarden dollar versprochen
das wird dazu führen dass lufthansa nach
dieser krise nicht mehr die größe nicht
geschlossen sondern der korona krise
gesehen hat vor wenigen tagen ja gut er
wird sich allerdings stecken möchte dass
sie mir nicht ernst genug nehmen das
land von den glauben sie hat sich
zufrieden gegeben sie hat sich zufrieden
gegeben damit das jetzt auch mal eine
emotionale rede gehalten hat und ich
fand es gab ehrlich gestanden ein satz
der mich stutzig macht mir wie du gesagt
hast du denken gibt in der rede und dass
das war sinngemäß ich wende mich heute
auf diese ungewöhnliche methode an sie
wenn die bundeskanzlerin eine rede ans
volk für eine ungewöhnliche methode hält
dann haben wir da ein ganz massives
problem denn das ist die normen normale
form von kommunikation des politikern
zum volk sprechen sollte die
bundeskanzlerin nicht als ungewöhnliche
methode wahrnehmen